will hunting vous dites que vous avez
commencé la corrida il ya un endroit je
me pose la question qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans votre vie pour vous pour
commencer ça est ce qu'il a un souci de
masculinité quelque part pour une
obsédante et payé combien
non mais moi lorsque je me demande
comment des gens moi je peux vous le
dire
la tauromachie à des avocats
extraordinaire les meilleurs avocats du
monde
un kick ass au jean cocteau et moi tout
ce monde est sérieux monsieur pardon le
décès de francis cabrel est ce que se
sont engagés en deux minutes il ya frank
leboeuf qui disent
[Applaudissements]
ct aujourd'hui elle est assez violente
pour qu'on veuille un minimum de
bienveillance un peu d'espoir et tout je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le public ne
souhaite plus des spectacles où on
torture tout simplement
mais bon je pense non je pense qu'en
2021 les gens ne veulent plus sain et à
nîmes pour vous dire il y à des écoles
de jeunes toreros ouvertement commencé à
6 ans si une caméra cachée par one voice
vous pouvez regarder images chercher les
tous sur internet et on voit par ce
moment où les parents signent les
enfants ont l'obligation d'aller
régulièrement là bas de regarder et
ensuite de passer à l'acte comment jouer
un enfant dé 10 ans vont à l'annoncé des
enfants ils en font des épées grand
comme ça dans des invectives ont demandé
d'excusés vous me dites ça comme si je
le cachais métier je mange comme si je
le cachais large et c'est ce que vous
dites il ya amaury d'ailleurs leveaux
qui je ne marche pas du tout j'ai jamais
été pour le magazine causeur à un
dossier bien combien vais-je et j'en ai
écrit la moitié puis on a on a réuni des
gens comme l'architecte rudy ricciotti
le chef étoilé pierre gagnaire et notion
vous avez dit excusez moi et je fais
fait deux pages sur le parcours d'un
jeune torero où on expliqué que les
écoles pour ims et pâques lâcher ben
quoi view
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors je vais
vous parler du paquet 6 5 pi 5 1 ça va
très très loin qui décréta la paye
l'excommunication immédiate des
chrétiens qu'ils assisteraient aux
corridas c'était en 1567 vous me parlez
de l'archi du d'accord ben moi j'ai la
plus touchante donc d'accord c'était
excommunication pour ceux qui a assisté
à la corrida
or vous pouvez me citer les figures que
vous voulez l'art l'art c'est sans ses
rayons des choses plus belle et magique
à les taureaux qui vomissent des
dizaines de litres de ces projets
et je suis du plus plus magique j'espère
monsieur excusez moi pour rendre vos de
papier là vous êtes prêt à dire
n'importe quoi et c'est gilles parlé
vous avez payé sans doute par le lobby
de la tauromachie vous voulez bien
il faut donc soyez honnêtes ils vous ont
donné de l'argent vous légitimez sur un
plateau de télévision la torture animale
est une ordure qu est ce que je vous
accuse
vous savez la différence entre vous et
moi je sais que tu sais que je les
voulais m'essayer noyer c'est que moi je
je je crois que vous êtes sincère
d'accord je vous crois nous crois que tu
est malhonnête voilà c'est dit les yeux
dans les yeux voilés maloney